he said every woman deserves to be quiet  okay yes now if a man my own opinion  right but if a man you but you've also  said courtship obviously being dating  without sex but you've also said that  women and men can date and you've you  just agreed recently  a man and a woman can it can lead to a  relationship if a man and a woman has  sex uh while they're dating so why the  [ __ ] is a man gonna waste all of that  why is a man gonna waste all of those  all of those resources that time and  energy on courting you with no guarantee  of six at the end when you can just date  you have six at the same time and get  the same loyalty and sustainable at the  end